with the day of destiny thumbs up it's
never-ending Road to Calvary where's the
child Cosette I want to make a film that
comes out and grabs you imax is the
perfect format for that the
extraordinary power of lame is and the
epic nature the storytelling and yet the
intimacy are things that primax do
better than energy however brilliant the
performances they needed to come out of
Club Michelle schoenberg's amazing music
which powering my name is Marines Tom
have seen because that I don't know what
to say rewrite it and to reconsider it
for the big screen it's been something
we've been dreaming of for a long long
time
film is gonna be incredibly exciting in
Iraq's we've got the most beautiful
sound that you'll hear on a movie in
many many years we have a 70 80 90 piece
orchestra at times playing this
incredible music in the imax theater on
those giant surrounds with the enormous
screen it's going to be quite an
experience I might go on your way
in imax it's going to be emphasizing is
going to day even more density and
emotion
you